we begin today in henderson where
neighborhood is recovering after that
overnight fire
started at a mobile home park last night
started at one unit
quickly spread to five others near warm
springs and lake mead
bianca holman spoke with residents there
who are now without a home
the american red cross is here at the
heritage park senior facility
helping those impacted by the fire
overnight they're providing
food water and accommodations for those
who lost everything
i went to let my dogs out and i saw this
glowing flame across the street i
thought was my neighbors
so i went out and checked closer and i
saw flames
so it it appeared to be a mobile home
fire so i got on my phone and dialed
9-1-1
just before 11 sunday night one mobile
home caught on fire in the alta vista
neighborhood
but the strong winds fanned the flames
quickly spreading to five other units
like lori connor's home the hot ambers
dropped down and caught the whole back
fits on fire and then two mobile homes
mine included and my neighbors this is
what's left of her home
clark county and henderson fire
departments rushed to put out the blaze
and rescued residents even cutting into
a fence so that people could escape
nathan boone who lives in the complex
also helped his neighbors get to safety
the shed was completely lit up in flames
completely crashing down
and so i just ran in there tried to pull
him out as fast as i possibly could and
then i ran to the next person tried to
help as many people as i possibly could
these are the remains from where homes
once stood where memories were made
destruction from a fire leaving families
homeless
our sign of father's day i want to
remember now and stop i don't want to
remember this one
we're told there were no injuries or
deaths in this incident
the cause of the fire is under
investigation reporting from the
southeast valley bianca holman
8 news now